ce sont des actes criminels voici
comment edouard philippe a qualifié cet
après midi les attaques et les
destructions ceux de ce week-end hier il
était nettement moins vigoureux dans les
propos et ça lui a été reprochée quand
il a dit cela
nous déplorons évidemment ces actes
imbéciles et violent mais nous sommes
déterminés à faire en sorte que ces
trafics puisse cesser alors ce matin le
gouvernement n'a pas manqué de se
démener en quatre ministres sur sur
place chanteloup les vignes et cet après
midi on a multiplié également les
déclarations un peu plus viril dans les
tribunes de l'assemblée nationale et
c'était déjà le cas notamment de
christophe castaner ce matin chez nos
confrères de bfm je souhaite qu'il n'y
ait pas un mètre carré en france où que
ce soit dans les quartiers difficiles ou
dans les villes préfectoral que
j'évoquais qui échappe à la république
la république elle est partout chez elle
alors bernard de la villardière à ce que
le gouvernement réagit mieux aujourd'hui
je suis passionné on jugera aux actes
mais enfin j'ai davantage de l'ag ce
fait incertain touche ces questions je
me souviens que quand j'étais rtl2
divise années 90 j'avais couvert les
émeutes de sartrouville et ma voiture
siglée rtl avait été retourné dans la
nuit on y est mille feux etc
c'était déjà des des bandes de jeunes
entre guillemets comme on disait à
l'époque face à des policiers venus la
sauvagère chevènement week sont ensuite
devenus soulageons etc et est donc j'ai
l'impression que l'histoire se répète
depuis une trentaine d'années faisait
une émission sur m6 a fait ça me révolte
début des années 2000 où on alerter sur
les pompiers les policiers qui étaient
de plus en plus agressés et aussi pour
ces gamins dealers qui était déjà
victime de rivalités entre bandes etc
je me souviens d'un éducateur social
qu'ils nous devaient emmener dans un
cimetière à grenoble et qui nous
montrait les tombes des jeunes gars de
entre 18 et 25 ans qui était qui était
mort sous les balles à cause de cette de
ces bagarres de territoire la part des
diverses ce trafic de cannabis trafic de
drogue n'a fait que s'amplifier
ça représente des milliards de
d'euros 2
d'économie noir chaque année alors il ya
eu la fameuse zone de non-droit on a dit
bon laissons les tranquilles
ça me permettra de préserver la paix
sociale et puis ça a duré vingt ans et
puis là dessus sont arrivés les
salafistes c'est à dire que les gars ils
se mettaient à dix les à 12 12 15 ans à
18 ans il termine en taule à 25 ans il
sortait de tôle et puis leur vie était
finie oui ils n'avaient pas de colonne
vertébrale il ya là dessus les imams
salafistes qui sont arrivés à main il ya
vingt ans en france et qu'ils ont
redonné une raison de vivre et donc la
drogue plus salafisme ça pour évoquer
les dégâts que l'on sait aujourd'hui il
ya plus de sept cents et quelques
quartiers en france qui sont jugés comme
ultra sensibles dans lesquelles la
police ne pénètre où les pompiers ne
pénètrent que caisse corte de voitures
de police c'est insensé
alors après je ne crois pas qu'il faille
leur faire la guerre enfin je viens tout
d'un coup m un déploiement de
gendarmerie et de policiers pour régler
la situation en quelques jours ou
quelques semaines je pense qu'il faut
d'abord faire la guerre au financement
de cette idéologie
voilà qui pousse au séparatisme comme
l'a dit françois hollande
une époque dans un bouquin qui est
devenu célèbre et avant d'ailleurs que
françois hollande
on parle donc fabrice d'avé ajar lhomme
et fabrice d'avs et il ya eu un atlas
géopolitique qui était chez un an après
les émeutes de 2005 signé de votre
maître yves lacoste béatrice giblin il
ya une page qui passe complètement
inaperçue où justement il pointe
ces émeutes et les risques de sécession
qui ont eu lieu
et quand on entend le gouvernement
réagir comme il avait réagi hier même si
aujourd'hui les mots sont plus forts
11e' mais est ce que on passe le
gouvernement les pouvoirs publics ne
passez pas à côté
due non seulement à côté du vrai
problème mais d'un vrai danger qui
danger de sécession qui existe depuis
des années déjà et qui a été pointée par
des géographes aussi éminent qui le
construit qui s'éteint qui s'est
aggravée malgré des efforts faits c'est
à dire que on n'a peut-être pas pris la
mesure des efforts qu'il fallait faire
on a quand même des quartiers qui
exactement
mais pas seulement mais c'est une
économie souterraine et qui permet de
maintenir toutes zones en relative
tranquillité parce que si on enlève cet
argent là on sera dans une situation
sociale qui sera extrêmement difficile
alors on fait donc d'aller justement
c'est sans doute beaucoup de beaucoup de
moyens beaucoup plus on dirait un ami
tellement d'argent dans la banlieue on
en a pas mis tant que ça dans la
banlieue d'ailleurs tous mes films et
que je dirais penser mais yamaha ont
construit des en avant à la mesure de ce
qu'il fallait faire on a habillé du
contenant n'a rien réglé du contenu
voilà donc on pouvait toujours repeindre
on pouvait mettre des grilles on pouvait
mettre des digicodes de tout ça on l'a
fait je suis d'accord avec vous le
conteneur n'a pas n'a pas bougé si vous
voulez avec un phénomène de ceux qui
peuvent s'en passer
partir partent puis d'autres qui
arrivent ça ce phénomème de noria qui
est extrêmement important et la seine
saint denis je crois que je la connais
juste là on va s'arrêter sur ce point là
mais est ce que par exemple avec si
c'est ça qu'il faut pour justement
éviter d'autres chanteloup les vignes
c'est plus de plus de moyens pas
seulement attendait tellement aimé ça
veut dire aussi plus de police plus
grand plus d'instituteurs plus plus de
beaucoup de choses à seulement plus de
justice oui la cible de deux temps et
cesser de courage de courage et c'est
mettre fin ce que vous venez de décrire
mais qui rejoint sujet dont on parle à
cet effet de noria le point de
l'intégration 6,6 chaque fois qu'on
essaie d'intégrer une patte de la
pollution de nouveaux arrivent mais oui
sous prétexte qu'on en a besoin pour les
entreprises parce qu'il faut que ça
coûte 10 coûteront moins cher mais ça ne
finira jamais c'est pour ça que pardon
mais les deux sujets dont on parle sont
liés oui et et donc il ya un moment où
si on veut que l'intégration fonctionne
il faut arrêter autant que faire se peut
les migrations
sinon on n'y arrivera jamais et ça sera
de pire en pire et on parce que c'est
vrai ce que vous disiez ça fait 20 ans
qu'on aura mais c'est de pire en pire
sire que les policiers aujourd'hui
vivent quelque chose de bien pire que ce
qu'ils avaient un temps et probablement
dans 20 ans il le vivront encore on aura
bientôt sûrement ses dires miss
l'intérieur qui le dit tout à l'heure on
aura un mort un policier qui se fera ils
se prennent des balles de pétanque sur
la tête il ya des tirs de mortier
comment dire hollande a parlé de
sécession maquereau a parlé de
séparatisme que l'on a dit en effet on
va on est côte à côte on va se retrouver
face à face c'est pas des dangereux
réactionnaire c'est pas le front
national c'est pas d'horribles
républicain qui mettent de l'huile sur
le feu pour attiser les conflits et
gagner les élections c'est simplement
des gens qui constatent simplement il ya
un moment il faut passer du constat aux
causes et les causes qu'on le veuille ou
non c'est quand même les conséquences
tous est d'une immigration absolument un
contrôle et donc oui il faut faire tous
les efforts que vous dites mais y'a un
moment faut arrêter cette noria sinon on
ne s'en sortira jamais ce qui est
étonnant c'est que le gouvernement n'a
pas bien valorisé pour le coup les
efforts qu'ils ont faits sur la seine
saint denis
il n'y a pas plus tard que dix jours
c'est à dire que moi je crois beaucoup à
cette logique de territoire est
d'arriver à un moment à se dire que on
peut essayer de construire des solutions
à l'échelle d'un territoire en mettant
tout le monde autour de la table et en
faisant en sorte que les politiques
soient un peu plus coordonnée parce que
je pense que c'est un peu le coeur du
problème sterk ont fait d'un côté des
efforts sur la police d'un autre sur
l'école mais on sait pas forcément avoir
des réponses qui sont pertinentes à
l'échelle du territoire
pour le coup ce qu'ils avaient fait là
c'est comme s'ils l'avaient oublié à
chanteloup depuis depuis samedi soit
donc on sait pas tellement faim je pense
que le règlement le spot c'est sûr vous
sûr parce que vous êtes en train de me
dire que en fait le problème par rapport
à la communication du gouvernement par
rapport à chanteloup les vignes c'est
que j'ai eu un problème de mise en
valeur de ce qu'ils ont fait en seine
saint denis la semaine dernière mais
dire que c'est la réponse qu'ils
essayent d'apporter enfin le sujet des
banlieues ça fait quand même un certain
temps qu'on n'entend plus tellement
parlé parce qu'on parle d'un gilet jaune
qu'on parle de la ruralité qu'on parle
d'autres problèmes en france à ce que
les médias ne peuvent plus y aller en
banlieue et il peut y aller et qui n'y
vont plus aidés et du coup effectivement
il ya beaucoup moins de sujets sont
révolus il a tout d'un coup ça ressort
est vrai que je pense la première
réaction est crétin parce que parce que
le geste est absurde parce que le geste
de violence policière qu'on connaît bien
qu'on connaît bien dans les yvelines
depuis quelques mois où c'est quand même
sous tension pour le coup se retourne
contre un équipement culturel qui
accueille des gamins du quartier et je
n'ai pas cessé totalement absurde donc
je pense la première réaction avait
juste se dire oui c'est que ces crétins
ou comme le pense cet internaute en tout
cas c'est ressenti de cet internaute
babineau qui lui dit il y avait une
volonté d'edouard philippe de
relativiser de minimiser le gouvernement
craint l'embrasement de certaines n'ont
effectivement la question c'est est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que je
pense que ça peut devenir un symbole
assez fort d'une reprise est
effectivement d'un sujet d'embrasement
des banlieues et c'est pour ça que ils
ont réagi ce matin assez fortement c'est
pour ça que tout à coup ils ont monté le
ton tous dans leur prise de parole pour
montrer que c'est non mais c'est une
force de faim tout ce qu'ils ont écrit à
l'attention sur le démantèlement des
trafics de drogue et c'est bien c'est
une façon de montrer aussi que c'est
enfin on a plutôt envie de dire que
c'est une réaction à une action du
gouvernement que dire c'est ccd actes de
violence qu'on ne maîtrise absolument
plus et quand c'est
y a pas de réponse l'affronter et puis
une situation qui était en train à
chanteloup les vignes parce qu'il ya un
gros travail qui est fait avec une mère
qui fait un travail de fond depuis
longtemps une situation qui peut
commencer à s'améliorer pour toute une
série de trafiquants il faut pas que la
situation s'améliore parce qu'ils ont
impérativement besoin de garder leur
situation de deux caïds et de petit
gamin qui met très tôt
soûlard sur leur emprise et surtout qui
déscolarisent tandis qu'une société qui
commence à bien aller pour eux c'est
vraiment ce qu'il peut y avoir de plus
gênant si vous voulez on entend beaucoup
cet argument c'est parce qu on les
déstabilise que ça peut être et c'est
entendu nous mais on va aller pas parce
que on dérange les trafiquants de drogue
et donc du coup on les déstabilise pas
en tout cas on les dérange et ils
veulent protéger leur territoire il ya
juste un quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas c'est que pourquoi la
simultanéité de ces explosions autour de
ce week-end d'halloween et de la
toussaint parce que on parle de
chanteloube les bureaux est rappelé la
courneuve béziers la haute garonne le
tarn et paie des impôts etc
on apprit ya pas eu 20 opérations de
police pour déstabiliser les bandes dans
toutes ces quartiers c'est donc bien que
ça oubliez aussi à toute logique
l'objet qu'il ya les réseaux sociaux des
tests intégrés on n'est plus dans une
odyssée tab sûr mais on est
malheureusement on n'est pas dans une
démarche rationnelle
s'ils allaient me dit protéger leur
territoire on serait passé démarche
rationnelle
on est passé d'une démarche sera celle
de protection du territoire une démarche
je le crains c'est ce que dit kepel une
démarche rationnelle de concurrence des
haines ou on va se payer du flic parce
que c'est comme une bande adverse on va
se les payer et quand on sait pas trop
où on va faire la fête à l'essai
halloween respect y ait du flip donc
c'est même pas pour protéger le
territoire
c'est plus que pour ça c'est il ya un
moment où il ya une sécession
c'est notre mieux et nous et eux nous
permettre de nous sait c'est effrayant
alors macabre onetto il faut revoir
entièrement l'urbanisme arrêté de
ghettoïser des quartiers je pense avec
ce que vous direz que vous trouvez que
c'est un petit peu léger comme comme
réponses oui non si on sent si on tirait
uniquement en repeignant les cages
d'ascenseur comme l'a dit michel rocard
c'était quand 88 la politique de la
ville
les murs d'escaladé tous ces trucs là on
parlait plus par les faiseurs du gilet
jaune c'est intéressant parce que
derrière la colère des légions ya aussi
le sentiment d'être défavorisé par
rapport aux banlieues et c'est vrai
quand on regarde l'argent qui est
dépensé en seine saint denis il faut en
outre en termes d'équipements publics en
termes d'investissements publics par
rapport à la population
on dépense beaucoup plus d'argent qu'en
corrèze ou qu'en lozère et donc les
gilets jaunes disent oui pourquoi cette
cocasse rien ils sont bien casser ces
salles engrenage met à parler de la
mixité sociale en biens par personne
évidemment d'air etc
on a on a essayé de faire un peu de
mixité sociale encres étant en créant
des zones pavillonnaires avec les des
petites maisons tympans des jardinets et
c'est tout près des cités mais ça marche
pas ça marche pas les gens achètent et
quelques années après ils chargent
d'amendé il sent bon on reviendra
également sur c'est sur ces questions là
effectivement sur les migrations
intérieures sujet je pense qu'ils
peuvent ou passionnés d'être éligible à
et comment la seine saint denis s'est
déplacé dans l'oise et en picardie